i want to let you know we got uh new be
good to yourself colorways
merch available now
hoodies crew necks and tees
also available is the i'm upstairs
collection baby let them know where you
are what are you i'm upstairs
and the new get that header bait and
tackle collection they got these hats
right there then brims baby
catch that fish in comfort now check out
that and more at theovonsstore.com
that's theovonstore.com
today's episode is brought to you also
by liquid death grateful for them
merry christmas to you
happy holidays uh
it's that time you know it's just that
time
it's that time to slow it down
it's that time to just really just
straighten out that snake
you know to to just
to even things out
to close up all the
if you got a couple pandora's boxes open
it's time to
shut them down
it's a time for joy
you know a time to give joy and
and receive it as well as you can
you know get out there tickle somebody
tickle a damn neighbor
tickle a trash fella the guys get in the
garbage sneak around the truck
tickle his ass you know be do something
bring some joy to
somebody you know hug a brother
get out there and hug a damn brother
you know
uh hug a white woman
email somebody email a filipino or a
dominican or somebody that you've never
met
a different specie a different uh
ethnicity
broaden your horizons you know
be a stand for decency if you can be a
be somebody who's
who just you just you just got a love
gun and that [ __ ] is full
and you just pop pop pop
you drilling people with joy
you can do it
get a nice gift for someone
you know get somebody something they can
use if you have a
maybe you got a buddy who's never been
to the beach
get him give him a little bucket of sand
or something give his wife a half bucket
maybe uh
maybe somebody don't have a legs or
something
you know
get them um
draw some draw a picture of them with
legs
and say hey man this how i see you
you know i see you complete
you know do something we had a
you know if somebody doesn't have a
tongue we had a fellow didn't have a
tongue bust and somebody wrote down all
the flavors on a piece of
uh poster board
so he could point at him when he was
enjoying something
look it's tart look it's you know fruit
based or whatever
oh [ __ ] this has lead in it and he
pointed lead
you know help somebody out
you know just be a stand for decency if
you can this time of year
you have a buddy that that um
that's never been outdoors get him a
tree get him a little tree bring it
inside
get him a little you know
get him a bird call or something hide
behind the tree
say hey this is what it's like
if you want even if you ever want to do
you want to be
brave you know we had a
a cousin that couldn't read
and um
and somebody got him a damn book and
that's not good
you know because that's really
get them a letter draw a big letter on
the thing say hey this is it l
m
r
you know don't
you don't want to ruin somebody's day
either
you know somebody can't you know i
remember he couldn't read they gave him
a book and everybody's like
you know because he can't
you know you can't put a toddler on
mount everest
you got to put him on an ant hill first
you got to think
but you got to love baby and that's what
time of year it is and i'm happy to be
here with you and uh
and merry christmas you know merry
christmas
you know damn just get out there and
just damn tell somebody
merry christmas damn it
damn
just if you got a damn ring somebody's
neck
if they don't get it
give it to them
merry christmas
you tell them it's that time of year
let's head in with a couple of beautiful
tunes right here
[Music]
you got somebody that likes to fish get
them a fish get them a damn fish save
them some time you know get them a carp
bring that [ __ ] home for them
[Music]
you got somebody that likes uh
animalia
trap an eagle for him
trap a damn american eagle form and
bring it home for you know just for an
hour let it loose baby that's god's nft
baby
let it loose but bring it home
it's that time of year
[Music]
you got somebody that likes to swim
get some water bring it up get you a
bucket of water get you a sponge
[Music]
and just
cut that corner they don't have to go to
the pool today say i got you ronnie
i'ma dampen your legs up i'ma
squeeze this sponge out on your back
squeeze this water on your back
i'm gonna let you know i'll even blow a
whis i'll even have you know have your
cousin dress up as a lifeguard and blow
a whistle once
we got you bubby
you ain't got to go to the pool today
we're bringing the pool home
god bless
[Music]
love you
that is julian julian brynn
[Music]
with joy to the world
and wouldn't it be great
if that if you could do it like that
if you could just snap a finger and
people
would just be joyed out
just women just smiling so big they get
lipstick on their earlobes
people just
just riddled with riddled with happiness
riddled with comfort
like they just swallowed a damn duvet
cover
just
just like they ingested them non-throw
pillows just
just full of comfort wouldn't that be
wouldn't that be magnificent
i think that's what i got to hope for
this time of year is that
it's just a
you know i get caught up in that in the
peril
you know
i get caught up sometimes in the peril
and that
in that dirt and that dirt oyster
and i'm in there just
sifting around for peril
but the joy is just out in the world
you know the joy is
is if i choose to
if i choose to be happy you know it's
it's a choice i have to make it's hard
sometimes but
this is the time of year to make it
you know this is the time of year damn
see a little child and just damn
you know
draw a damn mark on the beast on his on
his back while he's sleeping
you know put his shirt back on surprises
folks
you know i remember one time we do it we
had this fella named scotty on our bus
little scotty
and i think he was
i don't know if he was
he was uh
not deranged or whatever but he wasn't
you know they had decided he wasn't
gonna do well
you know he wasn't gonna end up top
shelf but he was
milling around he was a middle liquor at
the time
and um
and we you know
i don't know who did it i couldn't you
know i who knows who did it but people
drew swa stick on his back
and nobody knew what it meant nobody
knew that it was anti-semitic or
you know uh
they just seen it on pamphlets or
whatever you find in the woods
but um
but anyway i don't even know what that
story is about but anyway merry
christmas to you ah
and it's that time of year you know it's
that time of year where
you could really just hear you know you
could
you could hear santa just tightening up
them boots
just squeeze
just putting his fat just damn
just gristle hoofs just
you could hear them boots just
just squeak
just squealing like damn can we hold
santa again
and you could hear you know you could
hear him just tightening that belt up
just
that's the sound that buckle makes baby
[Music]
that buckle can't hold him
and as cookie crumbs fall across that
buckle because he's having one more
little cut
one more little dose
one more little upper
before he hits that ride baby you can
hear that belt just like
and you just hear him and he just
shoo he just puts his
feet into the sleigh
and he's in there
and his wife comes over and it could be
his second wife now
we haven't got a lot of intel
you know from that far north i think
the only person even up there anymore is
damn dexter
in his new season
and that's it
science light science
and i think the titanic is still crashed
up there
but there's not a lot of there's not a
lot of intel coming out of the north
pole
so he could be on his second wife you
know
some big you know breasted out latina
rolls up
with them f you know
them big funtleroys and milky funtleroys
on her
and she you know whispers something
naughty in his ear you know there is
at least navy daddy
something you know
and she might be dating one of the
reindeer on the side who knows i mean
things have changed and times are
different
and the reindeers out there don or
dancer
little daddy is you know they got
another they got a brother and then you
know little daddies out there
you know they got uh
uh
probably uh vato
they got a spanish one
it's a different ball you know it's
changed up
they got uh
on dancer on cupid cupid's a little you
know
cupid likes men and women that's his bag
whatever
all aboard
you know transistor is one of them
probably and he's double jointed down in
the freaking route
you know he's crotched out that
crotchety bad boy
but hey that's it
and that's the squad you play with who
you got
ben simmons is you know i'm saying you
got all types
you got everybody out there
maybe a little bit maybe a german out
there maybe an israeli out there
you got some you know all types of you
know
uh duster you got one of the reindeers
just damn addicted to huffing uh
keyboard cleanser
and you can't blame him
but that's the time of year it is man
and you can just you know
you got to believe that something
more unique is happening than what is
just occurring
in front of us that's what i have to do
you don't have to i'm not telling you to
but i have to believe if i want things
to be different or seem different or
i got to
believe that there's magic in the air
and this is a wonderful time of year
to do that so merry christmas to you i
love you
gang
what's happening what's happening
uh
oh i went to ufc 269
and dude it was
my god
i got there
and it was i mean it was so i went with
david spades you know him
and he's faint you know he's pretty
fancy you know he's
uh
tommy boy joe dirt
you know that you know he's that rascal
you know he's that rascal man
you cut on a damn rascal fountain and
he'll fly you know
he's the first
he's the first flow out that [ __ ]
and um
and man we were geeked up we went we
made some bets at the betting window
at the wynn
uh
motel we were staying at the wind motel
and
we made some bets over there at the
bedding window which was pretty cool
kind of old-fashioned
there's not a lot of part there's not a
lot of different par layout you just
walk up and you say okay i want this guy
or this horse
or
you know or this um
[Music]
woman you know there's just a couple
options
so we did that we put we laid some bets
down and then we went over to the fight
so why we get there
dude we're sitting right
behind dana white like i mean
like if he got covered we got covered
you know if he still even had a even a
vid or a co or a ov we got you know we
were right there we was breathing the
same
we was just volleyballing air and uh
and
and that was amazing and then david
sitting next to me then next to him
halle berry
from damn movies from damn you know
uh
wherever she's from
you know i don't even know
gorgeous town
you know uh finest fuckington i don't
know where she's from
but she just looked down vibrant
she looked like a shooting star it just
landed right in her damn heart
and it was just coming out of her eyes
when she talked to you
and i mean it just damn i mean
every time you know when you're just uh
and she loved fighting so she was we're
sitting there just chatting about the
fights
and um
yeah that wasn't that was
you know that was really interesting
um
then who else oh tommy lee the draw the
famous musician
was uh there
jared leto was there beautiful guy
dear god
i mean you look at the guy and you're
like damn
you like damn i don't know if this dude
is i mean is this dude fine as [ __ ] like
you just
you're like and you're not you're a
straight man you're like is this is this
dude fine as [ __ ]
this dude's hotter than uh probably some
of the girlfriends i've ever had
certainly mormon and my my first
girlfriend were really
really strong girl
probably six
six
six foot at the time and we were small
and i remember she would
and i've told this story before she
would uh
picked me up at the bus stop and she'd
put me around her waist and kiss me like
that
just just straight on kiss me like a
damn
god just like and she i think she shaved
dude
i think she shaved a little bit around
her mouth and
she would just
because i remember in the winter when
she would kiss me it would burn my face
a little
i just remember my face just feeling
like damn like i just done a damn
business meeting or something
and it was just a lot you know and she
played
i think she played softball i don't know
if we had a softball team she played
somewhere
but she said she did anyway she she wore
the uniform and
she was always punching the mitt and
damn i don't know but
she definitely
she really uh
she really had her way with me that
beautiful girl
what else
uh but yeah the fights were amazing dude
i got to see dominic cruz
so dominic cruz is a fighter he's an
american fighter
um and he looked like tom cruise he's
wearing
he uh
he had already had his fight and we got
there after that
so i knew he'd won because
i've been following him online but i
didn't get to be there and see it
uh
but he's dressed down now he's in street
clothes and so
you know he's just being right you know
he has sunglasses on he comes up and i'm
we're talking
and i'm thinking like i don't and then i
realized oh my god this is freaking
dominick cruz
uh so that was crazy justin gaichy was
there he literally just had just
backstage just like who gonna fight who
gonna fight who can i fight who can i
fight
so that was really magnificent
uh
thug rose
i mean it was just crazy just getting to
see all the fighters john anak was there
um dc
you know just getting to be in that
world for a little while
um al jamaine sterlings
uh
there's just every i mean and plus all
the fighters that were doing the
fighting
so it was just man
i felt like i was in a damn
i was just every i just felt so so much
possibility like i was in a damn
fallopian tube
you know just damn any just the word
just
god i just felt like anything was
possible
um
yeah so that was great obviously i was
really you know just i was bummed out
not disappointed
that dustin didn't get the victory but
uh
but he's a champ you know he's a champ
and um and he knows it and it is what it
is and
there will be many more battles and
uh
yeah and so that was my
i'm trying to think of anything else
that happened
while i was there oh
no oh they had one point where they got
spayed on the um tv where they like said
you know said he's there and i was
sitting right next to him and
some
a
a woman
came over with her kid to get a photo
and she's like will you get a photo with
my son
and
i got up to get the photo right when
they were like in a video spade sitting
there so
i kind of missed some of my
audio visual time on the
um
show but
uh
but whatever man it was just dude it was
and then you look there's just so many
fans and people are just amped up people
are beating each other in the crowd just
[ __ ]
there's somebody somebody brought a
scale and people were they were weighing
each other in the crowd like you weigh
130 you weigh 130 and people just
fighting
women against men senior citizens
against damn [ __ ] uh just cement
toddlers just everybody just
just
[ __ ] annihilating each other
and um and that was it man
that was it
uh
what else
all right let's get into a little bit of
news here
um
oh man i like water don't you
i like it
i'm glad they have it imagine if they
didn't have water
and you just always had to drink
something
what would i have
died dr pepper would kill uh
if you had a soda it would kill you if
you had just so much of it but
anyway
uh jake paul right here knocks out tyron
woodley in the sixth round to win the
rematch
um
good
uh what else
louis ck criticized for releasing the
new stand-up special sorry
his last special was great if you didn't
see it i know it's on his website
i'm excited to watch this one so i'll
um
i'll just tune in and watch it
you know that's what i'll do i'll tune
in and watch it he was nominated for a
grammy this year
for his other special sincerely
so
he's back
you know um
[Music]
and
yeah on that fight i guess just
on that woodley paul fight
woodley doesn't throw enough punches
you know and the fight is just a lot of
like punch inner you know clutch or you
know
hug
punch hug punch hug
they should lose a point if they hug
or
see who's willing to take it to second
base if you're hugging whoever you know
who's willing to you know
go even further a little you know what
i'm saying no my bruh but
you know cause y'all fighting or y'all
loving
nose boy because it's just those fights
it's a lot of just punch hook punch hug
a lot of the um
kind of like uh
these triller fights are select you know
the select this whole new
uh
zydeco of fighting this new
realm
it's a lot of punch hugging
and damn woodley got knocked out god
it was painful and at the same time i'm
just damn jealous
you know i'm like god i just
i'd love to be able to just sleep like
that
the rest he the immediate
it takes me so long to get to bed at
night
and the rest he got
i mean it was just immediate
you know no counting sheep no
uh
somebody sitting there reading you a
book
and you're an adult and you're like why
enough who is this
who's reading to me
um
none of that no meloton and none of it
just good and hot
good night
hello good night
and so that was just man that's the part
i'm envious it should be a hampton inn
commercial
want to get some rest
bam
try the jake paul suite
i want to say that if you had high
interest loan i've had them
i've had damn 17.70 or something
one of my loans i think was 40.58
i said well dad why don't you know
i don't want this it's a blender
i don't want this blender
the thing was damn twenty dollars and i
just got screwed into it at the
uh
mercantile when they said you want the
card too you want the option it's free
today
damn 18 or something i said all right
i'll take it
you know
later
you know i you know
every time i turn the [ __ ] on i just
hear myself losing money
just
damn poor
if you didn't have high interest
loans or credit card debt you'd be
feeling good wouldn't you
with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily
and start living your life
if you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never-ending cycle like
you're in a dang dryer you're in a dang
clothing dryer of debt just bring it up
right very good very good
who put a shoe in there
upstart can make you can help you make
that final payment so you can get ahead
it's a fast easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan all online you
don't have to go see anybody
credit cards high interest debt funding
personal expenses over a million people
have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment with a
clear payoff date
no more vagueness
for loans between one to fifty thousand
dollars
that's right find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
t-h-e-o
that's u-p-s-t-a-r-t
dot com slash theo don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application upstart.com slash
theo
that's what i got on that any more news
not much
um i want to let you know though i got
some new tour dates that you can check
out
and i'm grateful for them uh february
2nd i'll be in jacksonville florida
the third
saint petersburg
the fifth i'll be in orlando the 24th
i'll be in
lafayette indiana the 25th rockford
illinois home of the rockford peaches
and that's america's team right there
female ball
february 26 chicago illinois
uh
may 6th in tulsa may 7th in los angeles
um
yeah i just want to wish you a merry
christmas and a happy holidays and
happy kwanzaa if you do that happy
ramadan
if you do that happy damn
leap year whatever you celebrate
whatever you celebrate i'm going to wish
you it
you know happy uh
happy birthday if your birthday's on
christmas man you're [ __ ]
but happy birthday to you nobody cares
but
you do
and that's got to be hectic but
oh well you [ __ ]
um
yeah can you imagine having a birthday
on christmas you walk out with a
birthday cake
and everybody's like
we don't [ __ ] care
could you imagine that people you're
like hey come over here while i blow out
the candles
and people were like blow out my nuts
son
santa's here
you know when i was a kid i could
remember you would
somebody in our town one time when i was
a child
um
they would fly a pl like a
a small plane a crop duster or something
they would
i swear to god they
hooked like a
a trail of reindeer or something behind
like not real ones but you know
just i don't know if it was thin sheep
or it could have been cardboard
i don't know it could have been damn
emaciated uh
ponies i don't know it could have been
stuff you know i don't remember but they
flew a plane around town
and they would blast
uh
christmas music out of it
and it was just so amazing
you know it was just so amazing uh
because i remember my mom took us out on
the porch
and i got to look up at the sky and
there was it was like a sleigh it felt
like a sleigh like as a kid when you're
a kid it's like that's that's santa's
sleigh
going by and you could hear the music
and you just like oh my god
it's it's real
um
and i don't know if that was a city
thing they did i don't know what that
was i don't know if that was uh
you know if that was privately funded i
mean it could have been
you know it could have said pfizer on
the back of that i don't remember as a
kid i don't remember
but
i think it was just somebody around town
[Music]
had said i'm going to make today
i'm going to make this
better
somehow
uh
for not just myself
i'm gonna do something to make this
better for
for others you know
um
and it was magical
it was magical and i i even asked my
mother about this
not long ago and she remembers it
she remembers it
she remembers
that somebody went behind a damn crop
duster and was blaring music
that's how she remembers it kind of but
but i just remember it as just being
magic
all right as we get to these calls um
let's listen to one more little
christmas deal here
see what says this is from 1960s pop
christmas
the shake abouts
[Music]
okay that's a bit much that made me
want to damn eat my cousin's cat son not
doing that
let's listen to this one the eggnog
boogie
by chimney givers
okay
that's a little bit much
trying to relax over here we'll try one
more
um
[Music]
the first knoll
and this is by the shake abouts
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
and that makes you want to reach for
another cookie doesn't it
damn it makes you want to reach for
another cookie
[Music]
there you go and that is the first knoll
uh
and i look i like my mute i want my my
christmas i don't care if the house
burns down i want to be settled
somewhere
the fireplace going or somebody drew a
fireplace and uh pinned it up
and i want uh
i want that music
i want the mute i don't care if the
house burns down
as long as i can hear a peaceful tune
[Music]
i don't care if we never see the cat
again i don't care
i just want to relax
and hear a peaceful christmas tune
and have me a little cookie
the cookies i like the ones that moms
make
with just the sugar on them or the ones
that have the star in them
uh and they're star-shaped you know mom
gets the cutter from
puts it in there and the stocking when
moms make the stocking one that those
burn for some reason
the back of those always burn up
but then mitch is good you know i like
them
i like cookies that are burnt
i like a burnt cookie because you got
somebody to complain at
i like a cookie that comes with a reason
for me to [ __ ] at the end of it you
know hey
the [ __ ]
and you still
oh i'll have four more
i'll have four more of them burnt
[ __ ] but
you're gonna hear about it
amen
let's get into some calls man you guys
have had some good ones and i'm happy to
uh to address some of them thank you as
always for hitting the hotline
985-664-9503
all right
brother man this is joey donuts calling
from manhattan
joey don his baby from manhattan
them sugar circles baby
blessing us baby
with them glucose o's baby donuts dog
from the big s from the big city baby up
there in big apple country
big apple baby gang dominicans
so i've got a big date lined up in a few
days
we've got a couple mutual friends
we went to the same school but you know
i barely know this chica
i just wanted some advice you know what
do you talk about what should i say
first date i'm a little nervous
let me know what's going on brother man
gang baby i appreciate the question
there
and sorry to cut you off man but
i can and uh
and
here's the first date move here's the
first date move
you take the lady
to a uh
maternity ward
take her to the local hospital
i used to do this move when i was a
child pre-teen or teen you know
as soon as i was uh
you know viral or whatever sexually
mature
as they called it in science or
pre-science i don't know what we took
but i gotta be
but um
as soon as you're sexually mature and
you have a date
you should take her to the infirmary or
uh
maternity ward
here's what i would do i would take the
because we didn't have a lot of
attractions in our area
you know you could see maybe there had
been a fire you could go over there
you could park by the water
you know which is fun but
it just
it
it leaves all the other people coming
apart by the water usually deviant
you know somebody out there smoking a
pill or
uh people that want to have sex outdoors
and when you're still a youngster
you want to take her somewhere
that's at least
decently lit
you know so her parents don't get upset
so what i found was the maternity ward
you take her in there because you see
that the babies are in there
and you show a girl the baby you sh
that tells her right there a
you're a family man
you're about that life
okay you're about life you're about i
mean you're looking at actual because
the windows there the babies are in
there they got them in there you know in
the little uh
you know vestibules or whatever
so you get to see each one in the little
carton and um
beer so you're about actual life
you're about
life so you're showing her that
and she knows you're about sex because a
baby
you didn't get a baby without sex
you know that happened one time in the
desert
and that's that that's a that's a wrap
but since then it's taken a couple of
people
you know
touching
doing touch
so
so you let her know you about sex you
taking her dinner there's no sex and
nobody's
nobody's [ __ ] in the back so you can
eat at the applebee
you know there's not you know
there's not two people back there
fornicating
over there at the captain d seafood or
whatever so you guys can have a you know
can do a um
a shrimp shrimp you know basket
so but if you show her that baby it puts
it there's a thing that happens
where it just shows hey i know about sex
i'm sexually mature that's what it does
it lets a woman know you know about sex
you take her to dinner that doesn't mean
you know about sex that means you know
about recipes you know about silverware
you know about uh
you know
being indoors or whatever but you take
her to the
s to the maternity bam
she sees that and some of the babies it
still smelled like sex in there
you know the one in our town the window
was
was uh busted between the
babies and the um visitor
so you're sitting there you know what
i'm saying i think they even had a
little broken glass around there but um
yes you could still smell i mean you
still get that hit
and some of the babies they really they
definitely smell like uh
some of them smell like doggy style some
one of them you'll see still have a
panty wrapped around his wrist there's
some real
you know them italian ones there's some
real
it gets a little hype
so
that's your first day to answer brother
what you gonna take her to wear dave and
buster's take her to bust and busters
you know what i'm saying
gang baby onward
all right we got a call right here that
came in
see yo man you have the most
this has been from st you got the mo
what's up ben a
and st louis i don't know who is saint
louis actually
all right
saint louis
or louis the
nine
commonly known as saint louis
or louis the saint was king of france
from 1226 to 1270 and the most
illustrious
of the direct captions he was crowned in
the reams at age 12.
there you go
people i guess that's who he was baby
louie the nine
that's it
from posse france damn
well
yeah
there you go baby that's it dog if you
from posse
you must be
you a real you a real g in my book
that's for sure so i'm not shocked he
was a saint
um
what else do we have oh it was a call
that came in my bad let's hear more
this is ben from st though she's got the
most acute
baby syndrome in a man i've ever seen
you were talking to bryce in that
interview and you compared winning a
fight and the will to win a fight
to whether or not a man is going to have
children
you need a baby theo but your life is
too busy you might be a homosexual i
don't know
and you don't have a wife yet
well look man i would like to have a
baby
okay
but i can't have a baby with just a
penis brother
so that's first part
if i was homosexual dog
i would know
you know what i'm saying i've never
looked at the back of a man
i've never looked at the back of a man
like that if a man
even if i see a man who's painting or
doing something
and you see part of his butt a little i
don't even
you know i got a buddy
and he would uh
he told me one time and this is he told
me a secrecy but he's dead
uh
he said when he would see a man's butt
crack he would imagine nipples on his
butt
you know like titty nipples and i don't
even do that man so
if i'm ever thinking about something
naked it's so it's it's female
but
you never know
if i get hit by lightning or something
you never know or if i
i might
you never know you might fall in love
with you could somebody could come
across you that changes you you changes
your game
somebody could come across and you just
say you know what
sayonara [ __ ]
and you go for it so
uh as of now
i have no inkling to believe that but
you know if god wants it god wants it
baby let's hear more
well i do
i propose to you
that you impregnate my wife will raise
the child
will agree upon a price and you can see
him when you want to see him st louis is
pretty close to you five six hours uh a
price
so now basically you you trapping me in
the [ __ ]
so it's my kid i'm pregnant with the
wife
and then
but who pays who that'd be my question
because i'm you know what i'm saying i'm
running this high dollar root sauce over
here
i'm running this high dollar freaking uh
this wand uh chowder
so if you out you know
i got that real uh stick venom baby you
know what i'm saying i could sell dude i
could sell this
i could and my stuff's thick too i got
that preserves
so i could i'm sure
i could get a little dollar for this
so i'm just saying who's paying who
you know we need a passive source of
passive income
you need a son bud
okay so i'm paying you're saying you
need a source of passive income i need a
son but i'm not keeping my son you know
i don't want to have that you know this
song where you go see him like he's in a
stable or whatever
so
i appreciate it man you know i guess
could i impregnate that guy as a wife
i don't think i could man i mean i could
try but that's the crazy part if she and
i meet up at a damn days in or whatever
and you let me try and then it doesn't
happen
[ __ ] maybe
maybe i'll do that dude
dude i'll just meet up and try with her
for a couple hours dude or even four
even 50 even 17 minutes
so anyway man uh i love you guys and
thank you for the opportunity man thank
you for the opportunity and i'll let you
know if i need some of that
but yeah i've been thinking about maybe
it would be nice to have a wife you know
i need i'm definitely get because my
friends are all settling down
you know andrew schultz just got married
chris deleah is married bernie shaw's
married
i mean even just the
the dumbest people i know are married
so i'm like if they can do it i can do
it
so
oh people usually wait till after the
holidays to get healthy
i i do it i say you know what i
i was gonna start that diet but i'm
gonna start this batch of cookies
instead
i was gonna start to you know i was
gonna go for that jog but instead i'm
gonna jaw you know i'ma jog my tongue
across these damn uh
uh ginger snaps
you know i'm gonna hide a ginger
snapping somebody's ass i'm gonna have
it
i'm gonna treat myself
well
now you can kind of kill two birds with
one stone
you don't need to wait until the new
year to start achieving your fitness
goals peloton
makes working out simple convenient and
fun
man my ex-girlfriend got a peloton bike
and god
god she looks good
peloton delivers a workout experience
that's so exciting you'll actually look
forward to working out you just got to
create that pattern
what sets peloton apart is just they got
the good music they're dialed in with
the latest uh
you know video and audio support it's
just you don't feel alone
when you're using peloton you don't feel
alone
they make fitness entertaining that's
what i'm saying from hip hop to country
rock to pop everything in between get
free access to the peloton app
when you purchase this peloton bike
that's right visit
onepeleton.com to learn more
try peloton classes free
for the rest of the year new members
only visit one peloton.com
slash app app to learn more terms apply
peloton when your workout is a joy it's
a joy to work out
it's just about creating that pattern
finding uh just a
just
whatever is easiest for you to create
that pattern and i believe that peloton
is that
i want to let you know if you if you if
your testosterone is low if your balls
is feeling
you know
shallow
if you shallowed out in your nuts if you
really feeling hollowed out if your
balls feel like somebody knock on them
it would make a loud
like that
you know
if you yelled into one of your balls and
you could it would echo back
that's not good that's not good
what i'm telling you about if you're if
you're experiencing symptoms like low
energy fatigue erectile dysfunction
low sex driver libido or libido
anxiety brain fog enlarged breast tissue
bloating headaches
it could all be an indicator that you're
low in testosterone some of it could be
that's why i'm excited to share today's
sponsor let's get
checked let's get checked
okay people think it's like a it's a uh
it's cliff notes to how to play uh
checkers that's [ __ ]
let's get checked as the leader in at
home testing
for your testosterone levels
you just go to their site i've checked
mine
they're okay
could use a touch up
uh order the male hormone advanced
testing kit on their website it arrives
at your door in a small discrete package
that's right from there you do a small
finger prick send the sample back to
their lab with the prepaid shipping
label in two to five days you get your
results done completely online
if necessary a nurse will then contact
you for a consultation over the phone
let's get checked mail hormone advanced
test
is the perfect kit to get a
comprehensive look at your levels it's
fast affordable convenient and totally
confidential
use code t-h-e-o for 30 off your entire
order
just go to
try lgc
dot com slash theo
that's lgc for let's get checked
trylgc.com
t-h-e-o
for 30 off your entire order
at trylgc.com
theo
what else man let's take another call
that came in
um
what do we got here
do you believe
in
like
do you believe
in ghosts you know what i mean because
i saw a ghost man i think i saw the
ghost
yeah i know what you mean but
do you know what i mean yes i know what
you mean by ghosts
people don't say hey go you know hey i
was at the racetrack i saw those ghosts
going in a circle i know what you mean
you know we went fishing my buddy reeled
in a seven pound ghost i know what you
mean guy okay
thank you for the call also
and do i believe in ghosts
well
yes
because i you know i go uh i've i've
forgot something in another room before
you know you got to go get something you
leave something at home
or you have to call a diner in maine and
tell them to mail your air pod
um
i believe stuff all the time
so i can imagine a soul just kind of
leaves something but then you got to
come back and get it
you know
and i think it's easy for a soul to get
out of a body's pretty
you know a body is it's just a dirty
bird cage baby this thing is
it's not that strong really it's great
because it makes our all our organs just
be like a team but
it's not that go stab yourself
stab yourself four times man
don't call anybody for eight minutes see
how you do
you know what i'm saying
bodies only can only handle so much
and i don't i don't blame ghosts for
leaving somebodies
i don't blame ghosts for
some bodies if i'm a ghost i'm a spirit
i'm out some guy doesn't brush his teeth
for a month dude i'm ghosted i'm out
okay
some guy's in a domestic dispute dude
and him he's in a standoff with the
police
i'm out
i think you're going to see a lot more
ghosts because i think ghosts are tired
of being
we're just you know people screwing
around
just drinking damn mountain dews all day
if i'm a ghost and i want to do more
running if i'm that david goskins i'm
out
that that's probably who a lot of
spirits are a lot of spirits are just
a lot of ghosts are just uh spirits that
left home because [ __ ] was getting bad
in the body
you know you you realize you know
your owner or whatever can't read
and he's 30. oh mood
i'm leaving
goes by
i'm not staying around inside of
somebody at a certain point that's not
toeing there into the line
you know
you you dudes out there playing dice and
he's 41.
[Music]
i'm out
so i'm not shocked that a lot of ghosts
are really
i think you'll see more ghosts
because i think a lot of these spirits
are getting tired of they thought we
were going to do something with this
whole deal and we're just [ __ ] people
are just masturbating and looking you
know doing binoculars and [ __ ]
if that's all and i'm a spirit
sayonara i'm out
ever moved out of a bad neighborhood
that's that's a ghost
that's a ghost these days
the bodies they're in
they're not cutting it
and they just say hey
i'm done here
i'm gonna go look for something else so
yeah
i believe in ghostbub i do believe in
them uh
what else do we have let's see if we
can't get to one more call um
wait here's one that came in
well about theo vine this boy jeremy
from baton rouge
what's up brother jeremy thank you for
calling mate
i was going to let you know that i took
a trip over to
australia and i came back and i had some
cuts all over me and
my mom said yo where did those cuts come
from i said rise up live rise up lights
rise up lights
and she laughed and we cried and it was
a special moment but hey
i wanted to let you know that in your
episode you were talk about turquoise
hens or turkish skins i think you might
have meant a cornish head dog you know
the little the little chickadee that you
oh yeah the stuffing in or you get it
from the store
yeah brother thank you yeah turkish hen
baby oh no cornish hen sorry i could eat
about two and a half of the yeah cornish
hen it's you're right and thank you for
that man yeah i remember when my mother
dated a man
he had cornish he made us the first time
he ever had us come over he made us
cornish hens
and we're poor as [ __ ] i never seen a
real hen you know i'd never i didn't
know what
but i knew that this man it was real
weird he was feeding us these little
bitty ass chew you know
these are little children hens this is
this is uh
what a lot of uh
you know this is some epstein
appetizers baby this is
something uh
gilain maxwell would consider a delicacy
so
yeah and i just remember trying to eat
that [ __ ] and just
hated that man
you know because it just
it's already hard you're being a kid you
have to go to someone's house and eat
you don't know them
and they're dating your mom and then
they give you this little
and it just looks so more human you see
its little arms and its little muscles
god
it just felt like being in science class
like during like 11th grade but suddenly
they gave you a fork
instead of a scalpel and you're like
this is gonna be dicey
um
so anyway
yeah i remember those hands baby gang um
what else
let's take one more call man
hey yo it's alan from west la
i'm in the car right now it's a little
rainy so i hope you can hear me all
right
thank you for calling alan from west l.a
baby gang onward
i'm i'm calling it i'm trying not to be
emotional
um
these are these are happy here so
i'm i'm calling cause i just want to say
thank you so much man um
you know if you're ever wondering if
you're doing something good
theo i want to let you know that you
you've helped me so much in my life um
a few years ago i was i was in a really
bad spot
i was in
several toxic relationships with bad
people i was
stuck in a in a job or
i mean it was more of like a cult to be
honest i was brainwashed
damn brainwashed damn brother
my god brother damn
i'm sorry to hear it man
i can't i've never been brainwashed
really i mean we all have but i never
have been directly brainwashed man and
i'm sorry to hear that onward
i was dead broke
um
i had i had negative money actually
my account would get overdrafted all the
time
my savings and checking so i mean if you
gave me money i would still have zero
money
[Laughter]
oh dude that's wild if you gave me money
i would still have zero money that's
crazy onward brother i'm not laughing at
you man it made me laugh gang that's how
bad it was
when i was in that condition then i was
living right next to the great white
pizza i'm
going 17th so i turned on your podcast
and
i heard that your response by then so i
gave you a chance and
about you know a year and a half ago
i was listening and if you were
just talking about making changes in
life man and uh
you just you said this thing which
sounds almost silly but you said
it nothing changes if nothing changes
and
that gave me the strength to
to to do something and change my
situation and now i'm
i'm doing better than i ever have man i
have a
i have a partner who loves me and we're
doing great and
i have a job that's that's fantastic and
and i'm i'm saving a lot of money up
more money than i ever had in my entire
life and things are just going up enough
and
i just i just want to thank you so much
to you i i love you i love your podcast
and
i i'm just thank you so much for
everything you do man i appreciate you
okay
gang brother uh
thank you man thanks for the message oh
great block pizza baby yeah
1811 pico boulevard on the way to the
beach son gray block baby get that
hitter
man i'm happy for you you know i'm happy
that you're feeling better uh
i appreciate you calling and just
sharing that um
and that's all you man it's all you you
know choosing to do something different
in your life
um
you know that nothing changes if nothing
changes it's it's a great statement i
heard that somewhere
in an a.a meeting
and i shared it you know because it just
resonated with me so much and i remember
it all the time
you know that if something is going to
be different i have to do something
different
you know i can't
think my way in a positive action
but i can act my way into uh positive
thinking
you know and um
yeah i just said i could sit there and
think all day but it's not going to do
anything for me i got to move my legs i
have to move my heart
or if i move my legs it can it can move
my heart it can move my brain
but i gotta do something
nothing changes if nothing changes man
yeah thank you for reminding me of that
i need to hear that
so it's a statement that we share you
know and you hear it and
and and then i hear it and
somebody else hears it
and you know i'm trying to do something
i'm just trying to be loving this
holiday season i'm just trying to
remember that there's new possibilities
i'm just trying to remember that
um
that things could be
better always
even if they're already great there's
always room for things to be better
different or more unique uh
um
and that all things are really are
possible
and that may sound crazy to some people
but
i just think it all just ends in that
space that yeah if if i want things to
be different i have to do something
different
uh
you know it's it's just it's all just
memes at this point but
anyway man i love you brother and uh
and thank you for calling dude i'm so
happy that you're doing better
you know i'm so happy that you got that
fever you got that fire
that you decided to change something
and it sounds like once you did that a
lot of things have changed
so
uh
what else we've been offered to
impregnate a wife we talked about ghosts
um
let's take one more we'll take one more
here
hey yo what's up brother gang gang
brother
um it's cliff calling you from mr mask
what's up cliff from out there in
worcester mass baby onward i called you
before talking about my uh
alcoholic
ways bro i went to treatment i'm back
my son's second birthday tonight me
um i just love everything you do man
you're a great inspiration
um
i don't know what to say except for i'm
upstairs
all right brother
keep it 50
later
gang baby keep it 50.
i'll do what i can i'll meet you halfway
i'll meet you halfway it takes two to
tango it takes we can't do it alone
you know we got this
i'm so happy for you man happy birthday
your son's second birthday
and you sitting there
with a clear head and clear heart you
can handle it
and you dare and you you you're capable
of uh of being there for him today um
man that's cool
that's really cool man
oh
just happy for you
you know happy that you're living that's
living man
seeing a kid have fun and you put him to
bed and then you and you sit in there
with memories of it you sitting there
just caught up in the joy still of it
high on the joy
of other humans
and of love oh
it's good [ __ ] man that's beautiful [ __ ]
so
congratulations man merry christmas to
you
and to your little fella and
merry christmas to everybody i want to
thank everybody for being a part of this
podcast this year uh
i want to thank everybody that's um
helped produce this podcast this year
and just been a part of my life
um colin reiner raleigh mao
uh nick davis
um
[Music]
uh sean dugan jimmy rector
we've had a whole crew this year that
has uh chipped in and helped out it's
been a unique time
with moving around
and trying different things
and you guys thank you
and uh thank you for being a part of my
life
and if you need me
i'm gonna probably take a break coming
up in january here we'll have some guest
episodes that you'll be able to enjoy
um and those are all new guest episodes
uh those won't be repeats or anything
um but i'm just trying to focus on just
making myself feel pretty pretty well
and uh
and um
you know i haven't figured out exactly
how i'm gonna do that i'm looking at
some different options um and i'm gonna
choose what's just most comfortable for
me and um
and that's always evolving kind of
[Music]
but i'm grateful to you guys and if you
need me baby you know where i'm gonna be
son i'm upstairs
gang baby let's leave out in this uh
holiday tune right here
there we go
[Music]
oh
dude they say come a lot in this deal on
jeepers
um
[Music]
that is if you want to grab that you can
it's oh come all ye faithful by gregory
david
thank you guys for being a part of my
year man uh you guys be good to yourself
gang